[Música]
a finales del siglo pasado en la
productora audiovisual que teníamos en
gijón nos iba bien hacíamos muchas cosas
muy interesantes colaboramos con el
festival de cine de gijón hacíamos spots
videoclips etcétera y nos iba tan bien
que decidimos comprar equipo con la mala
fortuna de que a las pocas semanas el
equipo analógico que habíamos comprado
no valía para nada porque toda la
tecnología ese cambio digital tuvimos
que cerrar y yo me convertí en un
vagabundo hago mundo digital me reciclen
el diseño web en informática
programación etcétera incluso ayuda en
la transformación digital de empresas
hasta que fundé trans real 360 la idea
que yo les quiero que os quiero
transmitir hoy es como la realidad
virtual nos va a permitir transmite
trascender de simios a civivox y nos va
a otorgar superpoderes para ser
superhéroes y hacer del mundo un lugar
mejor
dice desmond morris la antropólogo que
somos simios desnudos primates sin pelo
o con pelo repartido de forma heterodoxa
y la realidad virtual es una tecnología
que nos va a permitir convertirnos en
sibos poco a poco cuando se vaya
incorporando en nuestros cuerpos
el primer super poder del que quiero
hablar es de la telepatía son tres tests
telepatía el transporte y los viajes en
el tiempo
para hablar de la telepatía tengo que
recordar en la película 2001 que para mí
es la mejor película de la historia del
cine en la que también se habla de
simios por cierto al principio y el
director de los efectos especiales de
esa película
douglas trumbull en 1983 dirige
brainstorm o proyecto brain store en
español y su lema era el siguiente
imaginé una máquina que graba
sentimientos emociones y hasta sus
esperanzas y sueños y piense que puede
transferir estas experiencias de una
mente a otra
esto es telepatía
para mí la telepatía es la máxima
expresión de empatía es la empatía en
grados supremos ponerte en lugar la
mente otra persona ocupar su ocupar su
lugar
esta película va de exactamente eso y
gracias a la telepatía y al poder de la
realidad virtual para hacer un mundo
mejor alejandro gonzález iñárritu ha
ganado un oscar con su experiencia a
carne y arena en la que nos pone en la
piel de un migrante mexicano atravesando
la frontera de los eeuu y quizá si trump
vivirá esta experiencia podría cambiar
su política avance a un mundo mejor pero
también podemos con el poder de la
telepatía con el súper poder de la
telepatía meternos dentro del cerebro de
un genio como es dalí y quizá si a esta
experiencia se la ponemos a un niño oa
una niña ese niño esa niña quiera ser un
artista pintor un escultor
hablaban voy a hacer un pequeño inciso
hablaba hace unos días con un amigo que
me decía aquí si no lo el tema de la
realidad virtual está muy bien pero es
que nadie tiene gafas en casa claro
nadie tiene gafas en casa porque no hay
contenidos para el gran público
no no ha pasado como con los discos o
los cds o con los vhs es que simplemente
fue cambiar el formato con la realidad
virtual de momento aunque ya esté ya sea
ya aplicaciones para muchas cosas no hay
contenidos para el gran público desde mi
pequeño punto de vista con mi productora
hemos producido anima una demo que lleva
ha ganado ha cosechado seis premios y
con la que queremos romper un poco ese
círculo vicioso en el que las grandes
empresas no invierten porque no tienen
nadie tiene gafas en casa y nadie se
compra gafas porque no tienen contenidos
que tendrían que pagar esas empresas
bueno ahí está pero además la telepatía
el superpoderes de la telepatía puede
cambiar la realidad en 2016 me contacta
change.org
porque estaban desarrollando una
iniciativa para cambiar el protocolo de
acoso escolar en las escuelas a través
de la colaboración con una radio online
hicimos un vídeo en el que una niña se
veía acosada por sus compañeros un vídeo
360 una experiencia 360 y ese vídeo tuvo
más de un cuarto de millón de visitas en
youtube no se puede ver ahora por temas
de derechos de imagen pero fue así y
consiguió cambiar la ley
este es el ministro de educación
recogiendo 212 mil firmas y se cambió la
ley para que en todo el sistema
educativo hubiera un protocolo anti
bullying es decir la realidad virtual
cambió la realidad real a mejor
eso es un poco la idea el poder de la
telepatía de la realidad virtual cambio
la realidad real
en el siguiente bloque les quiero
mostrar
es una imagen que puede herir su
sensibilidad
les quiero mostrar los efectos que tiene
la realidad virtual sobre un homo
sapiens cuando se le pone por primera
vez
aquí tienen al sujeto en un estado de
tensión
guardamos cierto parecido
y esto fue lo que en 2014 me pasó a mí
me pusieron unas oculus de cada uno las
primeras gafas de realidad virtual y
bueno esa expresión que tengo en mi cara
es la que se conoce como efecto wow es
un efecto qué
de sorpresa en cuanto a la inmersión y
fíjense que en esos en esa época en el
2014 lo que yo estaba viendo era algo
parecido a esto era algo súper cutre o
sea
muy muy pixelado con muy poco detalle
pero aún así he conseguido engañar a mi
cerebro gracias a que el poder de las
gracias al poder de la inversión en la
realidad virtual consigue
teletransportar me ese segundo
superpoder
esta es una resolución que apenas
llegaba al full hd
pero ya hay gafas como estas de la
escandinava compañía bario que son
capaces de reproducir la realidad a la
misma resolución que el ojo humano es
decir un contenido preparado bien para
estas gafas sería indistinguible de la
realidad evidentemente es un aparato es
un poco aparatoso pero nos va a permitir
competir nos en cybers porque va a
evolucionar de estas gafas a estas como
las que yo yo luego serán lentillas y
luego serán implantes quizá luego será
en nuestro propio código genético
observemos zyvox entonces gracias al
poder de teletransporte yo puedo por
ejemplo sin moverme de casa
ir al everest sin aguantar colas sin
tener frío
puedo por ejemplo bucear con tiburones
sin necesidad de dar clases de buceo y
puede que una persona que pueda
sometida a estas experiencias se puede
desarrollar el gusto por los deportes
por ejemplo de riesgo o el alpinismo
en el último bloque ya voy terminando
les quiero hablar de perdón se me
olvidaba también podemos disfrutar de la
desintoxicación a través de la realidad
virtual utilizando el teletransporte y
hablando de la experiencia que
mencionábamos antes de mondoñedo valley
que ha ganado un premio internacional y
que podemos disfrutar luego en cuando
acabe esta charla estoy con esto acabo
el bloque de teletransporte y les
terminó con el último superpoder que se
viajar en el tiempo hay una serie que ha
apostado a que la televisión pública ha
apostado por ella que se llama el
ministerio del tiempo y que
afortunadamente va a tener cuarta
temporada en esta serie hay dos
experiencias de realidad virtual que nos
permiten involucrarnos con la serie si
creamos buenas experiencias de realidad
virtual en cuanto a viajes en el tiempo
podemos por ejemplo viajar a la antigua
roma y si le ponemos a un niño o una
niña esta experiencia puede que de mayor
quiero ser historiador o también
hablábamos de que en el 2050 podamos
viajar ya a marte y si le ponemos esto a
un niño oa una niña que quiera ser
astrofísico
la idea con la que quiero concluir es
que la realidad virtual puede ser usada
para tener superpoderes que pueden
ayudar a mejorar el mundo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]